[موسيقى]
ودونالد ترامب وضعى بيضهما في سله
الانتخابات النصفيه ورهنا بكل مستقبلهم
السياسي في هذا الموعد حمله شرسه ركزت على
التضخم قدها الجمهوري الذين ظهروا واثقين
اكثر من اي وقت مضى من فرصه في تجريد
جوبايدا من غالبيته الديمقراطيه في
الكونغرس
الرئيس
الاقتراع سيمنحه نقطه انطلاق مثاليه
للترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد عامين من
الان وهو الهدف الاسم لترامب الذي يرغب في
العوده الى البيت الابيض من جديد
مقابل الرئيس الحالي الذي سعى للحفاظ على
تفوقه من خلال كسب الاصوات من اليسار
والوسط عبر تصوير المعارضه الجمهوريه على
انها تهديد للديمقراطيه والمكتسبات
الاجتماعيه في وقت بدت فيه جهوده للظهور
على انه رئيس الطبقه الوسطى لم تعطي
النتيجه المرجوه
انتخابات نصف الولايه التي تجر بعد عامين
من الانتخابات الرئاسيه تمثل استفتاء على
الرئيس الحالي ملايين الدولارات انفقت على
هذه المنافسات ما جعل منها انتخابات نصف
الولايات الاغلى في تاريخ امريكا ومن
خلالها تبدا خارطه الولايات تتكسف بخصوص
الرئاسيات المقبله بلال الوجداني العربيه
[تصفيق]